qui regarde François
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ton voisin alors hier soir forcément
alors sachez-le il y a eu plus de 20
millions de personnes qui ont regardé le
matière c'est que les chiffres aussi qui
a fait à peu près je sais plus comment
ils ont fait mais ça doit faire 22
millions en tout ou 23 millions pour le
match des Bleus c'était la folie dans
les vestiaires des Bleus après leur
victoire regardez
[Applaudissements]
et il y a eu un autre endroit en France
où c'était le feu c'est pas dans les
rues de Paris mais à l'Assemblée
nationale regarder des vrais Déglingos
évidemment pour adresser les
félicitations de notre assemblée à
l'équipe de France pour sa belle que ce
soit
à Théo et arandal nos deux marqueurs
qui vont nous permettre de passer une
séance sous les meilleurs auspices selon
pas douté
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
notre président Emmanuel Macron était en
déplacement au Qatar hier soir pour
assister à la demi-finale de la Coupe du
Monde interrogé par la chaîne l'équipe à
la fin du match il a analysé la
performance des joueurs et rendu hommage
à notre Didier Deschamps regardez moi un
petit peu particulier parce que le
président a évoqué la fameuse chatte à
Dédé
203 donc Didier Deschamps est là avec sa
baraka et son talent et on sera tous là
derrière donc on la gagne on ramène on
rapporte la coupe et il faut qu'il reste
évidemment qu'il faut que
on peut pas le dire il fait ça parce que
je voulais vous dire
Didier Deschamps qu'on fasse n'importe
quoi avec lui voilà on fait des paris
sur plein de choses et à chaque fois on
l'appelle la chatte à Dédé même lui il y
a un qui gagne un truc il dit c'est à
chaque année voilà
donc c'est vrai que tu le sais voilà
même voilà moi je fais partie du talent
exactement les seuls fois où il m'a
battu une fois sur 10 il a dit que
c'était grâce à la chatte à Dédé non non
on est trois partout là où 4 3 pour moi
enfin je suis devant le président a été
félicité les joueurs après le match on
regarde tout de suite son discours
regarde
[Applaudissements]
alors ça c'était la version soft de son
discours puisque on a eu la chance que
l'Élysée nous envoie son vrai discours
regardez beaucoup plus important
si vous ramenez la coupe vous pourrez
quand même Daniel Moreau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la fête dans toute la France va
vous montrer les images exclusives dans
un instant les bus sont qualifiés pour
leur deuxième finale consécutif de Coupe
du monde après avoir battu le Maroc 2-0
les affront donc l'Argentine dimanche
toute la France est heureuse toute la
France est contente toute la France et
bien sauf un relou
ce seront moins individus s'appelle
Michel silence
pour donner son avis sur la finale à
venir c'est comme si tu demandes à un
boucher donner son avis sur un
chocolatier non mais n'importe quoi lui
donne son habit surtout mais toujours le
mauvais michel Cymes apparemment il
croit pas vraiment aux chances de
l'équipe de France regardez c'est rasman
vous cache pas que je ressens aussi une
certaine inquiétude dans le disant que
si les Argentins nous ont regardé jouer
ce soir ce qui est probable ils vont pas
faire des cauchemars on a quand même
fait un hold-up contre les Anglais ce
soir on a frôlé la correctionnel aussi
moi je me reporte j'ai la joie ce soir
de la qualification mais je peu importe
quand même un petit peu dimanche et là
je me dis que Didier il va avoir pas mal
de boulot pour essayer de retrouver des
solutions parce que on a quand même
beaucoup beaucoup souffert
moi pour moi je pensais comme une bonne
nouvelle puisque michel Cymes c'est pas
non plus le plus grand visionnaire que
la terre est connue on a quelques
exemples à vous montrer en mars 2020 sur
Europe 1 avant le premier confinement à
cause du covid michel Cymes avait donné
son avis sur le virus
bon c'est un virus de plus c'est qu'on
le dit souvent c'est une forme de grippe
vous savez on a parfois dans certaines
années on a entre 8000 et 10000 morts
par an de grippe est-ce que vous pensez
qu'à chaque fois que quelqu'un est
contaminé au mort de la grippe ont fait
une dépêche AFP imaginez un peu le
nombre de dépêche qu'on aurait
michel Cymes ça c'était avant et au mois
d'octobre 2020 alors que la question du
port du masque dans la rue était au plan
cœur des débats michel Cymes a donné son
avis regardez rassera damus Michelin par
exemple je ne porte pas de masque dans
la rue parce que j'estime que ça sert à
rien sauf si on est dans une rue bondée
parce que commerçant parce que on croise
plein de gens mais voilà alors pour
revenir pour revenir au baiser oui oui
moi j'embrasse ma femme
j'espère qu'elle a pas peur en le
faisant quoi
en tout cas il y a une chose que
j'espère c'est que ces arguments sont la
finale de la Coupe du Monde il les a pas
volé à quelqu'un j'espère que c'est bien
à lui si je vous dis ça parce qu'en
février 2021 michel Cymes avait été
accusé de plagiat par l'un de ses
confrères Margaux qui accusait d'avoir
recopié son article publié dans le monde
intitulé amour et sexualité à l'heure de
la covid 19 pour une chronique sur RTL
on va voir certains passages où Michel
Cymes dit la même chose que le médecin
Marc goslan voilà michel Cymes le
visionnaire
michel Cymes le l'artiste j'ai envie de
dire donc heureusement qu'il est là on
lui demande toujours son avis il voit la
France perdre heureusement michel Cymes
dit qu'on va perdre je pense que si
Michel Cymes dit qu'on va perdre on a à
peu près 102% de chance de gagner
de covid-19 a eu des répercussions sur
la sexualité dans le monde entier dans
la mesure où elle a modifié et compliqué
les relations amoureuses entre individus
que ceux-ci soit confiné ensemble ou
séparément qu'il soit en couple ou
célibataire alors il avait il avait
avoué
complètement copié
et ben Michel c'est une regarde tu me
recopieras 200 fois pour lundi la France
va être championne du monde merci et je
crois qu'on a trouvé sa femme c'est une
journaliste qui était là pour bien
plomber l'ambiance hier soir le
président il était content on avait
gagné tout allait bien il faisait des
analyses sur le foot Didier Deschamps
tout le monde il parlait de tous les
joueurs il est connaît bien il connaît
bien et c'est vrai il disait voilà lui
il a fait un bon match je suis in qu'il
a fait on voit qu'il était vraiment dans
le match et il y en a une autre c'est
euh un autre délire c'est voilà les
relous sont toujours partout regardez
un mot sur cette Coupe du Monde au Qatar
qui était très critiqué nous avons
évoqué des changements concrets vous les
avez vous j'ai toujours été clair sur ce
sujet d'abord il y a des décisions qui
sont prises des années avant quand on
attribue une coupe ensuite quand elle
est là le sport doit rassembler et il en
est des Coupes du Monde de football
comme de rugby comme des Jeux Olympiques
il sera pour rassembler parfois pour que
des nations qui ne savent pas se parler
sur le plan politique se parlent et donc
d'ailleurs j'ai pu voir les miens du
Qatar avant dimanche je reviendrai et il
est prévu plusieurs rendez-vous plus
politique avec d'autres chefs d'État de
gouvernement sur des situations de crise
ensuite il faut reconnaître que le Qatar
l'organisme très bien cette Coupe du
Monde l'organisation est bonne la
sécurité est bonne et donc de dire
ne m'écoutons pas sur notre plaisir on
est en finale c'est formidable c'est
vrai nom mégotons pas sur notre plaisir
et après leur demander un autre truc
ils veulent pas kiffer les gars on est
en finale l'équipe de France je vous le
dit ils sont très heureux voilà ils font
une coupe du monde là les deux de chaque
côté du président
je vous explique un autre truc il y a
dans ce match une autre balise histoire
dans le match France - Maroc il y a une
belle histoire est-ce que vous avez vu
cette vidéo tourner c'est incroyable
histoire de l'abomance entre Killian
Mbappe et Achraf Hakim
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hier
il était particulier j'ai une histoire à
me raconter que personne ne connaît
il y a je crois que ça un an ou deux ans
ils sont allés au Qatar pour une
convention etc avant la Coupe du monde
je rafachimie et Kylian Mbappé et je
vous jure que c'est vrai Achraf Hakimi
lui avait dit tu verras on se retrouvera
dans ce stade pour une demi-finale ou
une finale de Coupe du monde
et c'est vrai que les deux s'adorent
lors de France Maroc hier il y avait un
match dans le match entre Killian Mbappe
et il se quitte plus depuis l'arrivée
d'akimi au PSG en juin 2021 dès octobre
2021 soit 3 mois après l'arrivée lakini
ils avaient tous deux est aperçu dans un
supermarché à Trappes regardez là ils
font leur course comme ça
en juin dernier c'était même ensemble en
vacances au Maroc et récemment pendant
un jour off du Mondial MBP était même
allé voir à Kimi dans son hôtel hier il
y avait donc l'affrontement tant attendu
dans les vestiaires avant le match il
était très heureux de se retrouver
malgré tout regardez c'est comme Gilles
Verdez et Géraldine maillet à la fin
d'une émission ils ont même échangé leur
maillot à la fin du match je pense que
vous devriez faire la même chose et
Géraldine
leur fans quoi c'est magnifique alors
pour résumer bon voilà regarder on a vu
un Killian rempli d'émotions même un peu
trop regardé apparemment voilà
[Rires]
en tout cas non mais c'est vrai qu'il
adore tous les